Allie:
Everything's complicated,
but there's always a solution.
♪♪
Gotta go.
Oh, hi.
How was work?
It was good. What're you
reading?
♪♪
Oh.
So you figure out where you're
gonna apply yet?
Don't know.
Josh and I are still talking
about it.
So that's still the plan? Follow
Josh to school?
Dina:
You and Mom were teenage
sweethearts.
Dina:
And don't say you had a bond.
Margot!
You want me to say we had a
bond?
Yes, I do!
Margot:
We had a bond!
♪♪
Allie:
Everything's complicated,
♪♪
Allie:
but there's always a solution.
♪♪
I've seen that car before.
Charlie:
From the bank.
Allie:
Those people aren't from the
bank.
♪♪
Hang on.
Allie:
Right now, we need to go.
They found us.
Allie:
We're gonna get somewhere safe.
So long, America.
Have a nice day.
♪♪
Dina:
What did he do?
I'm sorry.
♪♪
Shhh.
Pack one bag, be ready in ten
minutes.
♪♪
How much trouble are you
actually in?
Allie:
Enough.
Dina:
Not everything can be fixed.
♪♪
Allie:
Of course it can.
The trick is actually wanting to
fix it.
None of us likes this situation.
♪♪
Jones:
Unless we do the right thing
here, it will escalate.
♪♪
(Sirens blare)
What's about to happen might
seem like imperfect parenting.
♪♪
Allie:
This is gonna be an adventure.
♪♪
A bunch of fugitives are headed
south to Mexico.
♪♪
Dina:
I had plans.
Go to school, get a life.
Dina:
I can't just hide out with you
guys forever.
♪♪
What're you doing?
It's difficult to explain.
Hahaha!
♪♪
I'm interested in you, if you
are who I believe you to be.
I don't think we feel very
comfortable having this
conversation.
♪♪
Why are you doing this to him?
Why is he doing this to you?
Jones:
Dina...
Where are you guys headed?
♪♪